[Music]
if black is king
and beyonce is queen then her daughter
blue ivy
is definitely a princess because the
super stylish and charismatic
eight-year-old
is all over beyonce's new visual album
and we're running down her best
blackest king moments i'll be the rules
we first see miss blue during the
opening song bigger
as she sits cradled up on her mama in
the grand
canyon it was truly a journey to bring
this film to life
[Music]
then on find your way back blue stuns in
sparkles
rocking this shimmery look as she spins
inside a hoop
which we later see beyonce in our hearts
totally melted over this one beyonce and
her little girl playing a hand-clapped
game in the middle of mother nature
the way blue looks up at her mama all
the feels
on the front line on the song my power
blue and b
raw coordinated colorful looks and some
major choreography
[Music]
but the moment that blue truly stole the
show her vocals on brown skinned girls
i never anybody else singing let's
rewind and watch that one more time to
celebrate blue's star power
and this empowering anthem
the song which heralds the natural
beauty of black and brown skinned girls
features additional cameos by lupita
nyong'o
naomi campbell and kelly rowland plus
more of beyonce's family
including mama tina and blue's younger
sister roomie
and get this the track even made blue an
official award winner
at the 2020 b-e-t awards winner of the
b-e-t her award presented by kellogg's
is brown skin girl by beyonce featuring
blue ivy carter
wizkid and saint john my hope for this
film
is that it shifts the global perception
of the word black black as king means
black
is regal and rich in
history and purpose and in lineage
but blue's creativity isn't just for the
cameras
her grandma tina told et last year
they're having fun experimenting with
art at home
too i bought blue so many makeup kits
much to her her dad's dismay but
yeah because you know dads don't like
that but uh it's just for playtime
okay we have fun and she's quite a
makeup artist
is she yeah she's amazing what is like
her specialty
eyes oh my god she puts stones and does
all this fancy stuff she can do a
perfect cat
eye and when et spoke with tina in may
via video chat as she self-isolated at
home amid the coronavirus pandemic
she opened up about how challenging it's
been not seeing her grandbabies on a
regular basis
i'm facetiming all the time and my older
older grandkids understand it but
the two babies that are two they
are you know they don't really
understand so on
saturday we got together from a safe
distance we all went to uh bee's house
to get tested
kelly was there and i got to see my
grandchildren from afar
and it was hard but it was the best
thing in the world